[Music]
give
us your pupa you you're never gonna
get our pupa
unleash sci-fi hell
jesus that was the craziest battle
i've ever been in and all in one
unbroken take that must have cost a
million dollars
this is how are we
still so bad at this
hey we're still trapped on earth what
could go wrong
what's happening holy
this year i'm focusing on what makes me
happy i
adapted a high maintenance elderly dog
[Music]
smell my peen are these from brooklyn
you and i haven't had a night out in a
long time let's hit the strip
cocaine for everyone
[Music]
i'll admit this is going way too far the
solar opposites are going to jail
[Music]
[Applause]
how does everyone in this prison have so
many ships well they teach a shiv making
class on weekends play